the hills above alexandropolis are a
furnace of heat and smoke and Flame
firefighters stand toe-to-toe with the
blaze battling to push back the Inferno
but despite the crew's extraordinary
bravery the fires are being fanned by
gale force winds there is little that
can be done to stop them
our own house up there where the fire
started has completely burnt down there
is nothing left now the fire is moving
downwards towards the rest of the
village
fire only fire that's what we could see
the wind was so strong no one could do
anything no one
it's here that firefighters found 18
burned bodies on Tuesday as sharp and
shocking increase in the death toll from
these wildfires this region is close to
the border with turkey and authorities
say the victims may have been migrants
trying to reach Europe
[Applause]
the blue lights of ambulances snaked
their way through the city and Convoy as
the glow of the advancing Wildfire grew
brighter and closer to the suburbs at
the city's two hospitals the time for
hesitation was passed from one 200
patients many of them elderly and frail
had to be evacuated to safety every
available vehicle was pressed into
action even removal Vans and laundry
trucks they were taken to the city's
Port where a passenger Ferry has been
hastily converted into a floating
Hospital the passenger Lounge now
repurposed as a clinic patients placed
on mattresses on the floor nurses
tending intravenous drips and oxygen
lines
I really haven't ever experienced this
before and I've been working for 27
years it's like War conditions stretches
scattered everywhere patients here
patients there reinforcements are on
their way 56 firefighters have already
arrived from Romania and more personnel
and Equipment are on their way from the
Czech Republic Croatia Germany and
Sweden that is welcome news but for
those who've died here and for villagers
who've been displaced from their homes
it is already too late a terrible
Twilight has enveloped the whole area
the smoke has turned the midday Sun
black the glow of flames brings
destruction and death John saropoulos Al
Jazeera alexandropolis
foreign